live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I am Dave Ramsey your host this
is your show I don't know if you've
heard or not but you're going to lose
all your money the stock market is
crashing because the British have left
the European Union with brexit had you
heard everything's gonna fall in we're
losing all everything we own it's all
going away
oh wait that's so last week did I not
tell you this was gonna be a great yarn
I did are you ready everybody together
mm-hmm
was a great yarn wasn't it you're not
going to die
he's like Mark Twain said the rumors of
my death have been greatly exaggerated
but boy if you watched Fox CNN MSNBC CBS
ABC who did I leave out NBC you would
have thought the freakin world was
coming to an end and I told you it's
gonna be a collective yawn it's even
gonna be a collective lawn yawn for the
Brits as a matter of fact it's the UK's
gonna come out way ahead because
sovereignty is like this cool thing
where you protect your borders and have
your own economy that's like something
countries do and it's kind of cool yeah
it was gonna work out guys those of you
in the UK you're gonna be fine those of
you don't like it - stop your whining
you're gonna be fine you got outvoted
you lost move on yeah sorry
no you didn't lose anything it's all
back and went down they came back and
all week so you just we just have we
have this penchant for drama the 24-hour
news cycle makes stupid stuff that is
not news news
and turns it into big news I mean it's a
big deal no it's not I was talking to
these executives the other day in the
advertising world they said have you
seen our TV have you seen the ads on our
our product our TV ads and I'm sorry
I'll watch TV much like never I did this
I have this weird habit from the olden
days I read it's it's a weird thing most
people only know what that is anymore
but that's I actually read and my wife
actually reads and so she has the news
on when I get home usually so I end up
watching a little bit of that and then
1/8 dinner and then I you know look at
her and I go can I please turn this off
because the stupid stuff starting to
come on the TV by then I mean have you
looked at network TV it is it not the
definition of stupid seriously and we
spend our time putting that trash in our
brain and wonder while we our brain is
rotting
so brexit didn't kill you you didn't
lose all of your money you're not going
to die everyone I told you in the middle
of it when you were all screaming and
worrying and fretting it was one week
ago it was gonna be ok by the 1st of
August it was gonna be a distant memory
you wouldn't even remember you wouldn't
be able to spell brexit by the 1st of
august we remember what it meant and it
didn't take any time at all for it to be
a collective yawn everybody on three one
two three hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you